okay good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the Macmillan Center I'm in
Shapiro and I'm moderating this panel to
discuss Johnny Steinberg's book the
number let me say a little bit about my
motivation for putting together this
panel and I'm very happy that everybody
has agreed to come here and discuss this
book with us today I would say that I
had two principal motivations in in
wanting to do this this year while
Johnny Steinberg is here as a visiting
professor one is that I think the
numbers just hands-down one of the best
books written about South African
politics in a very long time and I
thought it would be a very good moment
to revisit that this book now that we're
coming up on its 15 year anniversary of
its publication but secondly I thought
it would be a good occasion to visit
some of the wars and debates however you
want to talk about them about the
methods of studying politics that you
know the joke about political scientists
is how many does it take to change a
light bulb you know 19 one to hold the
latter one to change the bulb and and
seventeen to argue about the methodology
but rather than talk about methods in
the abstract I thought it would be much
better to discuss what we think about
qualitative methods with an example of a
really high quality example of a piece
of work done with a qualitative
methodology so that's sort of going on
in the background I think we could have
I hope we can have a productive
discussion about methods
in connection with evaluating this book
so Iowa I've always thought it's best to
talk about methods in the context of the
concrete use of methods rather than sort
of abstract discussions beyond that
there are three three sets of issues I
think that this book puts on the table
that I hope we we will be able to
discuss obviously at its core is this
discussion of prison gangs in South
Africa which I'm 26 is the 27th and the
28th about which I'm sure our panelists
will have things to say but there are
three other or three issues that are
going on in at least as well that I hope
we might be able to discuss some one is
that because this book looks at the
South Africa through the lens of what
went on in prisons before during and
after apartheid that sort of raises
questions about what in the economic
social and racial stratification of
South Africa is due to apartheid and
what is due to other forces and I think
that's something we could profitably
meditate about a second set of issues
and debates has to do with power this is
a book about power among other things
and if you think about the the sort of
debates about power in political science
that have gone on since the 1950s there
were people like Dahl rewriting in who
governs who said power is pluralistic
because different kinds of power
exercised by different elites in that
case it was a study of New Haven and
then he had critics who said well let's
look at people who don't have power
maybe power circulates among elites but
there's some people who never have power
and this led in part to the phases of
power debate but go ventus book about
power and powerlessness
looking at the powerless Jim Scott in in
earlier work also looked at the weapons
of the weak people who don't have power
what Johnny's book puts on the table and
I hope we can have some discussion is
that Macomb placated view the either
from the top or from the bottom because
he looks at nested power relationships
that the these gangs in the prison
certainly exercise huge amounts of power
from some perspectives but they're also
clearly in the power of the people
running the prisons and then the larger
political system so how we should think
about nested power relationships I think
is is another interesting set of issues
that maybe we can we can spend some time
on and then the third is more explicitly
methodological that this is that I'm
trying to think of a term to
characterize the genre of which this is
an example and the the word which maybe
is occurred to others before but the
word I've come up with it's a kind of
bio ethnography in that it's an
ethnographic study but it's it's also a
biographical study of a living person so
it's using this this study of the life
of mucky teen Wenzel as a window onto
other things but it's it's it's on it's
unlike other ethnographic studies in
that Johnnie developed a relationship
with the subject of his study over a
long period of time which offers
opportunities but also I suspect
methodological challenges from the point
of view of the author the only other
book I can think of in recent times that
I would put in this this genre also an
excellent book is an on go calls book
about Afghan
there are no good men among the living
which is also a bio ethnographical study
in this sense that it's it's a very
close to the ground examination of
Afghan politics through the first decade
of this century and he follows three
three people and I think one could have
some productive conversation about this
genre by looking at books like that so
those that that's the sort of general
motivation for the panel and some of the
issues that I hope we'll be able to
discuss but I'm sure there'll be many
many others that come up so Johnny
Steinberg is a professor of African
Studies at the University of Oxford and
and here as a visiting professor at Yale
for the year teaching to seminars which
are you won't be surprised to hear
packed to the gills my absolute maximum
Mahmood Mamdani happy to have him back
at yale we're always happy to have an
excuse to have Mahmood here professor of
government at Columbia University and
also he is the director of the makarora
Institute for Social Research at ma
carrera interested University in Kampala
is probably the biggest university in
that part of the world and my mode being
Mahmood he really is full-time person at
both places and so constantly run off
his feet James Scott is sterling
professor of political science and
anthropology at Yale Elizabeth would the
Franklin mozzie crosby professor of the
human environment and professor of
political science at yale and so our
procedure is going to be that Mahmood
Jim and Libby will each speak for about
ten minutes first then Johnny will speak
for about ten minutes then we will have
some back and forth on the panel before
opening it up for general comment
and questions so welcome all and my mud
Thank You yen happy to be here I have to
admit that I didn't know about this book
when Ian sent it to me and said you must
read this and of course once I started
reading it I couldn't put it down
and it's a compelling book it introduced
me to a world which I hadn't really
known and for me it it's an opportunity
to reflect on two issues that I work on
so it's a great book and and now I want
to discuss where I want to to have a
conversation with you so this is these
two issues of violence and identity
violence is pervasive in this book the
system infantilizes the inmate it blocks
the road to manhood for the prisoner
this is not me talking this is this is a
journey talking and and violence is is
part of the search for identity which is
a search for manhood and you suspect the
search for humanity although that word
is not used by the author but when is
struck by the centrality of violence
it's everywhere it's suffocating you're
blinded by almost a pornography of
violence and and and you wonder is there
a way out
but there's never a reflection I didn't
find a reflection on this question is
there is there a way out of this
violence the world inside the prison is
a violent world waters and gangs fight
over prisoners non-goal OSes capture is
becoming a warder happens at the same
time as the gangs move from outside to
inside the jails and establish a
parallel power structure in the jail I
wondered if there was any connection
between non Belleza becoming a warder
and the gangs finding cover inside the
prisons only those prisoners who
establish mastery over violence are
acclaimed as real real men these are the
twenty sevens the upholders of law who
must spend a lifetime in jail learning
to embrace and live with violence and as
the gang seek to establish control over
violence they kind of try and seek to
play the role of some kind of a state
including on asking the question who who
can pronounce death often the violence
seems gratuitous out of proportion to
the outcome this much may be stolen but
the victims are killed the author tells
us that this extra bit of violence makes
sense if understood as political
gratuitous violence is crime that
borders on politics it's part of a race
war
for example the doggy dog story 1996 now
I want to return to this as I discussed
the question of power and identity so
they start with the Foucauldian familiar
Foucauldian formulation power produces
the subject and the subject mimics power
the subject is made by power the author
tells us the criminal system makes
criminals
out of decent people the present system
becomes home to criminals prisons are
the networking center for criminals in
South Africa when prisoners organized
their mimic organs of the state if they
are organized as an army so are we if
they have a judge so do we and so on em
so let me come to mic on comments here
one I think none of us chooses an
identity that for me is the starting
point okay em it's not the starting
point in the book but it could be the
starting point in the book none of us
chooses the identity in the sense that
we are all named by others modern power
imposes an identity on you in South
Africa it defines you white African
Indian color these are not chosen
identities okay these are imposed by the
state on on own subjects now the subject
is produced by power and produced in the
sense that the subject mimics power so
in this South African world Africans
organizes African National Congress
Indians organizes Indian National
Congress
coloreds organizes colored people to
Congress White's organizes congress of
democrats it's embarrassing to say
congress of whites but that's however
only the beginning of the story it's not
the end of the story so what is the
story the story is that identities also
transformed now the book closes with a
celebration of freedom dean maha dean
has the name pronounced maha Dean Martin
Dean chooses to become a Christian
chooses to become a Christian he chooses
to look to the future rather than to the
past now this is a happy ending and a
happy ending is tempting but it's not
always convincing okay and I'll tell you
why I wasn't oh it wasn't totally
convincing to me
the change of perspective is of vital
significance but but a choice he makes a
choice and and he makes a choice from a
menu and like any menu it both offers
and limits our choices ok so so I want
to look at these two sides of it at the
same time the menu changes over time as
choices are produced new choices are
produced so if we look briefly at the
history of these identities in the South
African context so we begin with the
identity colored now this is an identity
imposed my view imposed by the state
then come other identities both
state-enforced and those produced from
within societies so two two tendencies
johnny discusses which seek to flatten
the past one he discusses in the context
of architecture the cozy Ayers radical
urbanism unleashed in district 6 on bulk
up I guess
and the other is born-again Christianity
which he says tries to wash away the
past but Johnny says things are never
quite like that the past is all always
part of the present I agree with it but
then we'll come back to it the next two
are more important the third identity
which is of the Cape Malay the Muslim
now Maxine is not colored he's certainly
not black
he's a cape malay am i right okay so
he's a cape malay this is not a
state-enforced identity neither is it
really a slave identity because the
muslim is more than a slave why does a
slave become a muslim is it just because
the master will not let him be a
christian cause the state says you
cannot enslave christians
that's what the author implies but I
think there's a larger story here this
is a part of the story which needs
telling I remember I was three years in
University of Capetown and at that
period I remember reading a masters
theses from University of Natal written
in the 70s on early Afrikaans known as
Arabic Afrikaans
because early African slaves slaves in
South Africa came with their own
intellectuals Imams unlike slaves who
came to Americas in America as the
intellectuals were weeded out Imams were
weeded out okay not allowed to come in
but in South Africa they came with their
with their with their with their own
Imams could see a John could see Adi the
writer once explained to me the
influence of Malay in early Africans now
here's the interesting part
early Africans was written in the Arabic
script before being romanized okay the
first two publications in Africans were
commentaries on the Quran published by
the Ottoman Empire so Islam is part of
the slaves claim to manhood Islam became
pop became part of the slaves claim to
humanity was Islam an alternative to the
embrace of violence and the mimicry of
power that's a question ok in a
particular historical period I don't
want to generalize this across history
but in a particular historic then we
come to the next phase in math Dean's
life which is so Ito and Black
Consciousness and this is discussed more
fully and and and we get this Jack's
level interview the ironies of you WC
colored youth talking in Afrikaans as
they mobilize around BC after Soweto
Martine is now between crime and
politics Black Consciousness is an
identity transformation for coloreds as
it is for Martine I presume because we
don't get much of a discussion between
this
this discussion of the outside and
what's happening on the inside this
Martine what is the connection between
the two we know his part is paying
editing in it to some extent now Martine
becomes daryl right he Martine becomes a
Christian the author tells us that
identity is not a discovery from the
past but a pragmatic choice to make a
future I wanted more
I wanted the choice to be located I
wanted it to be contextualized from the
Cape Malay Marteen Marteen becomes a
Cape Christian or a black man is it a
response to Soweto and BC how do we make
sense of it as the author tells us
earlier when discussing born-again
Christianity's claimed to wash away the
past that things are never quite like
that is Christianity a different kind of
choice after black consciousness and so
at all the combination of ethnography
history political analysis is powerful
but it leaves some gaps my questions are
to one that the discussion of identity
as something voluntarily embraced leaves
out of sight the fact that identities
are in the first place imposed not
chosen to there are two kinds of
identities identities which simply
affirm and reproduce the relationship
with power which involves no more than
the mimicking of power and then there
are identities which tend to be
transformative and and and here I think
we need the author to give us a slightly
deeper look at it at Cape Malay and
Islam and a black consciousness and
Christianity if I had more time I would
have talked about the need for a
comparative approach how
how that would have assisted comparative
meaning looking at outside South Africa
thank you okay
don't forget you said that right well I
mean you know God be tailor-made so in
violence it it strikes me okay here
violence becomes the weapon of choice
for reformers so you have these reformer
Afrikaners who want to save and
civilized colored children colored
children and then they basically
terminate the relationship between the
father and the kid they want to save the
kid from from the drunkard who would the
father has become and and of course it
brought to mind the Indian caves in the
u.s. the Native American kids in the
u.s. being forcibly sent to these
schools to be to be educated to be
civilized it also brought to mind
because I have been recently reading a
lot about Israel Palestine the design is
forcibly taking hold of infants of Arab
Jews the MS Rahim in the 60s and
actually taking all of babies and and
and and sending them for adoption and
telling the parents that the babies died
in birth I also had questions or tough
questions but thinking about so the the
gangs in the super gangs who ruled the
flats and and it reminded me of of
native areas of Nairobi at the time of
mama in the 1950s and and and studies
which which show that of course all the
police budget is spent the police's in
the white areas and then some of the
police's in
in areas and almost no police in the
native areas and the gangs are also the
weapon that maintains order in the
native area okay it doesn't just suck
police police also extort wherever they
do they don't extort as much in the rich
areas but but the gangs don't just
extort they also maintain some kind of
an order
so this proto state in in in the book we
get a sense these are not Robin Hood
types these are they prey on the weak
they prey on the poor they prey on the
migrant laborers etc they're not Robin
Hood types they're not Hobbes bums
social bandits but sort of I looked for
parallels I thought of the story of Boko
Haram which is also a very interesting
story because because the story of Boko
Haram has a connection with the with the
African story the swahili story the
house a story because the original Boko
Haram is founded at the time when when
when the script of house'
is changed from arabic to to the Roman
script roughly the same time as that of
Africans is changed to the to the Roman
script and Boko Haram is founded to say
Boko Haram Boko his book book Haram the
book is sinful if the book uses the
Roman script it is sinful right but what
what the change of script did was it
rendered an entire generation illiterate
because you couldn't read now write the
language of reading was gone it was a
new script a script you didn't know you
you you became completely completely
illiterate so what was the social
protest first Boko Haram then becomes a
gang and then becomes a becomes a
militia a mercenary militia you know but
it goes through
stages of transformation I mean I
thought that it would give us kind of a
thank you
I'm going to make gonna touch one two or
three themes running leave aside what
for me is one of the most interesting
themes and that's non goals of US
history and the way in which it was
mythologized by the gangs and came to
stand for something that did not
represent the actual historic activities
and it seems to me that one of the
things Hobsbawm does teach us although
these are Avengers and not Robin Hood's
is that in fact what's most interesting
about any of these groups are the
stories made up about them by succeeding
generations and people who look to them
as a kind of touch done for their own
orientation and has nothing to do with
what they actually did in the world so
you know Jesse James was not a nice man
but the stories about him have him
coming home and teaching Sunday school
and helping old ladies across the street
and that was in a sense made up by
people who celebrated Jesse James
because he was attacking the banks and
railroads who were exactly the people
that the Missouri sodbusters hated most
that's the subject I'm not going to take
up I I think this is the most brilliant
granular examination of a prison society
and prison identity that I've ever read
and one of the things it does as if
perhaps we didn't need to have it done
again is to have us understand that
prisons are not panopticon's a lot
Bentham in which the prisoners are
atomized sealed off from one another in
which there is this one eye surveillance
eye with total power that controls every
aspect of their life prisons are run by
prisoners but as Marx will say not quite
the way they might like to that is to
say it's run by prisoners within limits
as Johnny so careful with plays so the
world is divided into nighttime and
daytime and who controls these spheres
of
today the limits on prisoner violence to
the point where the length of the blade
of a knife is specified so that you do
not actually kill someone but wound them
grievously because everybody understood
stands if you go further you're going to
get murdered by the wardens and the
prison guards so that there is an uneasy
collaboration between the waters and the
prisoners and the structure of their
cooperation seems to me to try to avoid
the worst outcomes for each of them it
is a kind of order although at the and
then last analysis the waters break ties
if you could put it that way
second theme is the question of how
prisoner organization mirrors resembles
distorts mimics a lot of words have been
used already the world of apartheid and
governance outside and here I guess I
want to read what maka would actually
refer to in passing but I would like to
read the entire paragraph because it
seems to me to be extremely important
about the process of power in the prison
this is what page number is this I'm
afraid I have a different book it's it's
about 183 okay the figure who emerges
from the initiation rituals having been
beaten taken after de verga
subject to a sulfus diet is really a
distilled version of a man the sort of
man a second-rate philosopher cobbles
together notice philosophers in the room
he consists in a few hard shorn virtues
and nothing else
one is solidarity but a solidarity of a
very particular ilk the recruit is to be
robbed of a part of his own physical
integrity for the sake of the gang his
sacrifice is visceral and highly
personal
he feels it on his body the second is
stoicism it is critical that the
recruits show indifference to his pain
he must not cry out when when beaten he
must emerge from isolation unscathed
this is perhaps the starkest and most
striking of the virtues of the
initiation Foster's the recruit must
demonstrate the ability to amputate or
at the very least to stunt vital needs
feelings and responses so the price in
the sense of one's manhood comes at the
that's the once manhood comes at the
expense of cutting off these features of
human experience and what did these men
do with their newfound manhood they
become in essence a mirror to their
custodians we went in here as a kind of
indirect quotation that Johnny uses we
are what you are you are an army we are
an army you have a head of prison we
have a judge where you have a head of
section we have a general whatever you
do to us we will do to you in turn far
from resisting Authority they are locked
into into it like a deer in the
headlights their aim is to mimic it is
internally the question arises if they
mimic the structure of power in the
society would we be able to look at
different kinds of prison systems
elsewhere in the world and infer or
deduce the kind of prisoner society that
would arise I think it might be possible
I can't attempt that here
I gave Johnny a copy of varlam shaman
lofts a large book called Colima tales
700 pages on the Gulag Archipelago a
better writer and a more astute observer
of human sensibilities than Solzhenitsyn
was I might add and he describes a world
of I guess he would call the
unter mention on the one hand and the
gangsters on the other hand and the
gangsters control everything in that
prison society all the privileges the
ability to stand next to the so stove
the ability to get the easy duties to be
gotten to the infirmary where they can
rest for a few days and so on so there
at least have hear him tell this story
it's a world divided between people who
don't account who are feminized and
infant alized on the one hand and
gangsters on the other I know because
it's in this bibliography that Johnny
has read Matheson's book on Norwegian
prisons in which being Norwegian prisons
all the duties of prisoners are spelled
out precisely the way a sort of work
form might be in a Norwegian company and
a point system is established because of
the pressure of the prisoners to say so
many days of good behavior will get you
a conjugal visit so many days of good
behavior and work will get you a certain
privilege in terms of watching TV later
having foods shipped in and so on and
the guards in that book as I recall it
were complaining because their
discretion had been taken away they were
dealing in a sense with trade union eyes
prisoners who had mastered the system
and were gaming it and they were
deprived of all of the discretion that
they had which you understand that
discretion is the source of warden power
and they were deprived of it because of
the syndicalism if you like of the
prisoner force Johnny says that this is
these are not like extermination camps
not like Auschwitz Bergen Belsen and so
on I wonder if that's entirely true that
is to say the accounts that I've read of
such extermination camps is that some
people survived and the desire to live
created a class of prisoners who
took bodies to the pits for incineration
who were given duties that preserved
them from going to the ovens themselves
or the gas chamber themselves and so
there was a kind of very small remnant
who were able by a kind of collaboration
to be able to survive under these quite
extraordinary and foremost people
totally deadly projects I I imagine that
there's a book or dissertation there of
comparative prison cultures and the kind
of prison society cooperation solidarity
and behavior that it breeds I want to
say something about the kind of
ethnography this book represents and
this is something that Ian urges us to
get into it is an extraordinarily
reflexive ethnography and is to say and
it was it was noted in that way by an
interesting review in the Los Angeles
Review of Books that compared
Venezuelans social history of cuss mine
it's an oral history of a sharecropper
in South Africa with Johnny's book so in
terms of reflectiveness it seems to me
that certain ethnographies assume a
quasi deist view of filling in all the
details and having in a sense the
ethnographer disappear all together as
if you're seeing this may it might be a
kind of brilliant view by x-ray
helicopter or what-have-you but the
ethnographer disappears then there's if
you like the post modernist view that
there's nothing really out there except
me looking at what's out there and my
internal interpretation of what's out
there so let's talk about me and that
then gets to be a kind of solipsistic
version of ethnography that seems to me
to lose a good
deal of its value I think that Johnny's
ethnography keeps its eye on the
protagonist to Magadan
wensel but never forgets that he brings
certain things to this encounter himself
how his presence structures every
relationship by either implicit or
explicit relationships of power by the
structures of power the news it's
outside and in this respect it seems to
me he does an extraordinary job of
giving the floor to his his protagonists
I want to read one other extraordinary
exchange which I don't think one would
find even in the best ethnographies that
I'm familiar with I read that this is
Johnny writing of course I leave the
prison that day feeling Hollow and
unhappy in writing this book I have used
the words I and me I say to Magadan I
say to Magadan Magadan tells me as if we
are equals we are not the relationship
between a journalist and his subject is
never a relationship between equals the
eye in the pages of this book the
journalist the eye in the pages of the
book the journalist pens is not a
flesh-and-blood being with a soul to be
bared in a heart to be scorched he is a
cipher an abstraction he is a pair of
eyes that sees all the subject on the
other hand the Magadan he is the one
with the bared soul and scorched heart
the eye is capable of doing him violence
and then as I said he gives Meggitt in
the stage he says to Magadan this is not
what you expected what do you mean
magnatum says why you were so keen to
have a book written about why were you
so keen to have a book written about
your life when we met it was like you
have been waiting for years for me to
come along and when I do arrive it's not
what you thought I make you into a fool
I bring these documents that make you
feel like an idiot
he sighs deeply and shakes his head no
he says it's not that you are making me
a fool not a fool but a little baby you
were the one who came in here with
stupid ideas
you thought you could get me to tell my
story without causing me pain are you
mad
how can I talk to you about my life
without feeling pain I wait for ten
o'clock and I think Jesus what is he
going to ask me now is he going to ask
me something something important and I
will have forgotten you know what the
conclusion was I came to last night I
told myself if I hadn't been so [ __ ]
angry all the time if I hadn't been such
a rude negative bastard for twenty-five
years I would have been more observant I
would actually remember my life even a
lot of inmates and year remember
remembered me from the old days and only
after we start talking I begin to
remember I feel I am losing something I
am afraid the more my memory goes the
more my life goes so yeah every time you
come to this cell I'm scared scared that
I haven't been there for most of my life
scared you will have discover something
about me I can't afford to remember but
you know what I'm a guy who speaks his
mind if I didn't want it I would have
thrown you out long ago I would have
said Johnny it's been great you're a
great guy but this is [ __ ] me up
we must stop thanks for your time so I
actually don't know of an ethnography
where in a sense the ethnographic
present situation and power and
relationship between the in agra fur and
someone who is the subject of a kind of
oral history gets to be so displayed in
a way that gives a reader a kind of
sense for how fraught these
relationships are finally I guess it's
clear to me that a book like this
we'll teach you more about the society
of prisons and warders and power under
extraordinarily constrained conditions
then a six-foot shelf of sociology about
prisons in general so at this level as a
kind of deep biography and an oral
history it succeeds I think brilliantly
the question is what would have been the
alternatives of a study like this there
is a non Salons oral history of Casa
main called the seat is mine which is
one of the true truly great oral
histories that I'm familiar with I've
taught it often but it takes a
completely different view and doesn't
get into the relationship between the
ethnographer and the protagonists the
other example that I'm extremely fond of
which is another step in a different
direction is Theodore Rosen Gardens all
God's dangers the life of Nate Shaw it's
a southern sharecropper between the wars
who went to prison for being a kind of
militant and a sharecroppers
organization but it is a purely oral
history that is to say after an
introduction by the person who collected
the if you like it did the interviews
and just listened to this man he didn't
ask any questions this man just talked
and talked and talked and so the
creativity is in the editing which the
person who wrote who put the book
together talked about but there is
nothing but there are no dialogues it is
just the words and stories and
subjectivity of the protagonist who was
Nate Shaw it's a different name we now
know what the name was and it is an
extraordinary extraordinary book and it
like Johnny's book will
you more than a six-foot shelf of
economics about sharecropping in the
cotton South in that in that period the
last possibility of which I only know
one example and it the reason I raise it
is because it's the one example I know
where there is not an interlocutor
either the interlocutor is invisible
assumed or the interlocutor is there and
you begin to grapple with the
difficulties of understanding what's
going on here and that is Maria Karolina
Davis's book called child of the dark
this is a salt Rio de Janeiro ragpicker
and it happens that her mother was a
servant in a well-to-do family when she
was little and she was able to sit in on
the tutor that came for the daughters of
the wealthy family and she became
literate literate enough so that she
kept a diary and just for herself for no
one else just for her diary and I guess
the pleasure of writing one day there's
a fire in the favela and some
journalists are there and somebody makes
a comment about the favela and she said
oh I have that in my diary and the
journalist says your diary and they go
back and finally her diary is published
the last picture in the in the in the
printing of her diary in the book that
prints are diary has her leaving the
favela with all her small belongings she
leaves but I recommend it as it doesn't
happen often but this is an ethnography
for oneself an auto ethnography this
woman had no reason to ever believe that
anyone would read this but her and so it
offers that kind of ethnography without
an interlocutor messing up the situation
with their priors with their face with
their history
so all in there is a research method and
it does so in quite specific ways I'll
mention just three here valuing the
measurement of causal effect over the
demonstration of causal mechanisms
descriptive inference and the
documentation of lived experience
through interpretivist research valuing
the inferred structure of choice the
strategy set preferences rankings and
expected outcomes rather than the deep
descriptions of perceptions of choice
the complexity preferences and the way
that outcomes are conditional on
emotions history and commitments and too
often limiting qualitative research
methods to semi structured interviews
usually with Elise ignoring the
potential of other ethnographic methods
such as participant observation oral and
life histories and participant mappings
this compelling book can and should be
read as an intervention in the
discipline that demonstrates the power
of ethnography as a way of knowing its
most compelling contribution is in the
interpretive this vein I think it's
mapping of when CIL's evolving
understanding of his identity the
challenges he faces and the dilemmas at
its heart the book is a remarkable oral
history constructed through interactions
with wensel over the course of many
months johnny pays close attention to
the arc of the narrative to the ordering
of the stories to the silences and the
contradictions that biden tells him he
analyzes this complex narrative as the
construction of meaning and identity
which is sometimes most illuminating
when it is in sharp contrast with the
facts for example the timing of his
first dimension detention for activism
not at the time of the Soweto riots as
he recalls but it must have been a few
years later so it reminds me in some
ways of another oral history that I
thought I'd mentioned by the great
Italian oral historian Alessandro tele
it's called the death of luigi trois
Dooley and
it's tells the story of a through oral
histories of a trade unionist who was
killed in a wave of mobilization after
the Second World War people remembered
him having been crucified up on a wall
at a time of this great mobilization
when in fact he was killed not by being
crucified up against the wall and at a
different time but the point is the
social memories of his death and the
cultural and political work that that
did so I thought I'd flag which the what
were the most powerful of the themes in
the book for me one was the power of
myth and narrative to produce social
structure and meaning the gangs
regulation of sexual relations in
prisons as Johnny puts it repeatedly and
obsessively redrawing the line of
acceptable relations the complexity of
governance of prisons the role of
violence but also of consent and the
reciprocal de-escalation proposed by a
visionary colored water working with
wenzels
so let me read just a little bit about
this Jensen the order was in essence
establishing the terms of a pact the
running of the prison bureaucracy would
lose its dictatorial arbitrariness all
aspects of prison life would be
administered in consultation with
inmates he was paired to open up the
prison there would be cricket soccer and
gym
run by inmates themselves but they had
to play by the rules he was offering
them slivers of freedom in exchange for
de-escalation and it goes on about that
so the wenzels a fourth and very moving
theme is a one so struggle to change his
life he his own project to refound
relations with his family to reassert
his name to live a life of dignity and
respect one long undermined by his own
reliance on another identity as a gang
member
his deeply troubled relationships with
women particularly his mother and his
hostility to middle-class colored people
and also to white people so what's
I want to read you another passage which
is about his if you like conversion so
how did he begin to find another way of
life and it had to do with this
partnership with the warder he was a
sucker for Jansen's bargain it fired his
imagination at once he read it not as a
strategy to tame the prison but as an
idea powerful enough to redeem his whole
life and he goes on to say the narrative
offered by Jensen was a Christian one
about redeeming a wretched path a
political one about resurrecting a human
being out of the deformed soul apartheid
had created it was a narrative that not
only braced the fact that he was a
criminal it placed the criminality in a
grand story made the path from
criminality a political and religious
Odyssey it it put himself at the heart
of the story gave him the power of
comprehension the power to look back at
his political history and make sense of
it when I asked him why he embraced
Jensen the warders so quickly and so
wholly he frowns at me not bothering to
conceal his disappointment as my income
at my incomprehension again we have this
tracking of their relationship to you it
seems quick he says to me it seems like
it was very slow a whole lifetime I've
been trying to change for years so I
think political scientists are very
stupid about conversion experiences and
and also about their limitations
so as Jim pointed out Johnny also draws
on other methods to construct this
argument it's not solely an oral history
there's a lot of participant observation
so one feels like we're visiting the
prison with Johnny we're driving with
wensel to visit his family were
shadowing orders there are also
interviews and sometimes oral histories
with other people in wenzels life and of
course
Johnny's also comparing documents with
their time stamps and the differences
between policies on paper as implement
and as experienced by the inmates so the
book also makes notable contributions to
descriptive in
reference for example documenting the
structure the practices and culture of
the number gangs documenting the wardens
offer in the inmates response that I
just read and arguably make suggestions
of causal inference suggestions towards
building theories of self-organization
and total institutions of violence and
more specifically of the role of violent
initiation practices all of these are
current themes in the literature on
political violence by armed
organizations so for example I thought a
lot about the practice of sexual assault
within the ranks of the US military as I
read this book so one aspect of the of
the text that I wanted to point to
specifically that I found particularly
striking is what can be read as the
careful construction chapter-by-chapter
of ethnographic authority so what makes
a good ethnography what makes an
ethnography a credible deeply persuasive
piece of social science research as Jim
I was as Jim was I was very drawn with
the skill with which Johnny practices
what ethnographers call reflexivity the
ongoing reflection on his relation with
Wenzel its evolving ease but also the
very particular tensions the occasions
when he the the researcher is surprised
and asked himself why exactly was I just
surprised so I was gonna read you the
extract that Jim just read you we I
guess we both liked that passage a lot
but I'm gonna go on so this is after
this difficult conversation between
Johnny and oneself and he he and Johnny
it's been great you're great guy but
this is [ __ ] me up we must stop
thanks for your time he goes on to say
Johnny says the things you need to from
me you need from a counselor or a
therapist not a writer and wensel
interrupts I have seen a lot of
counselors and therapists I saw one from
the UC T it was good he said anytime I
think I need therapy I must phone him I
haven't pwned him with you high have
gone further I say in things I say and
think things with you I can't with
counselors I have chosen you because you
are good for me can you understand that
I have chosen you Johnnie replies I'm
writing a book for [ __ ] sake I'm
sharing your pain with the world wensel
replies you're treating me like a fool
again you know what I want to write a
book about my life but I can't
it's too [ __ ] painful I need you here
I need you to take me to the man I used
to be and I can't get there myself and
the result is that it's your book not
mine that is the price I am pain Johnny
says I'm not sure you know you're saying
only when you've read it in black and
white will you know what it means for
someone to write a book about you once
the replies do me a favor shut up and
write your book let's stop saying model
and this model than that it's giving me
a headache just to write the [ __ ]
book do it from your heart make it true
to have how you have experienced me do
that and I will be proud of you notice
the inversion going on here
Johnny continues I shut up the subject
had dusted off his most eloquent words
and shut the eye up but he had of course
told the eye precisely what every eye
wants to hear
he had Asajj my bad conscience had given
me license to scorch his heart and open
his soul the victory was mine not his
and it left me feeling no less anxious
than before so this is such a remarkable
encapsulation of the very complex
negotiation that goes on in this kind of
sustained ethnography so the other piece
that I wanted to pull out as
particularly powerful in this reflexive
mode is Johnny's reflections on the
ethics of field research and also on so
for example his respect for the silences
on the part of people that he speaks
with so for example he doesn't approach
family members at some points because it
would be too meddlesome it's two
previous it's not the right time and he
also traces ethnical dilemmas that he
confronts this asymmetry between him and
wetzel as I just showed you it's not
exactly as eight so asymmetric but there
is this deep asymmetry in resources so
Johnny has two straw
with the after he comes out of prison
for the final time the the deep poverty
that wensel is suffering and what he
Johnny can can and should do about that
so fittingly the final words be law
belongs to Wetzel who thanks his brother
and friend Johnny Steinberg for giving
me the opportunity to tell my story a
story untold and that that's the end of
the book which I'm still digesting very
experienced
so I'm also a disadvantage because
you've read the book I haven't read it
since it was published that that tried
to immigration for this so it's been 14
years so I I can't respond to everything
that you've said no but I can to some of
this but I thought that maybe what I do
is is take a everything you've been
quoting is very sort of intimates and in
a graphic and I draw back from that and
maybe respond will part I think to TN
into manhood and and the first is about
a path it's and and you know what prison
gangs might have to say or might
illuminate about political history you
know the political history of other
country and to do that one needs to
situate them in historical time and in
politics
and you ask what here is apartheid and
what is social forces beyond the party
it's all rather than apostate I mean one
way to understand apartheid in its
entirety is is as a a moment in a much
much longer history and that history is
this I wouldn't say
exceptional situation one word since
you've written so much about traffic and
not be an exception but a an unusual
situation where a unusual situation in
the history of Empire we're colonizing
and colonized people share a territory
in large numbers and neither is going
away neither is decimated and they have
to figure out things and I think a part
it may be best described as a massive
lung holding action in that history by a
group of people who really did not want
to know what to do next and decided to
wait I think that that's really what
apartheid was it was a very very long
wait for an inevitable political
integration and I think for the party
its clearest thinkers absolutely knew
that they knew that it was temporary and
lack of imagination didn't know what to
do next and so designed this intricate
system of waiting and in one level it
was enormous ly successful first year at
last a long time it lasted 46 years
secondly almost all white people were
much much better off at the end than
they were at the beginning
white prosperity grew immensely and
literally almost everybody
during those 46 years and then white
people negotiated a transition in which
their children would retain you know as
valuable enriched social capsule as they
had under apartheid and so so the
prosperity would go on more generations
in that sense in that narrow sense it
was a hugely successful project it also
had massive massive costs one was white
fear and disinvestment from the future
which is a feelings which were actually
contagious in which some black people
caught something we can maybe talk about
later but in other was the black
suffering as a result of the way sing
and I think that's where prison gangs
come in and where they're understood and
and part of that suffering I think is
best understood in the currency that
people like Frantz Fanon and albear
Mamie spoke about about humiliation
about striving to be human
and you know prison gangs long proceeded
apart sets but apartheid amplified
everything about them in sheer numbers
and and essentially what they meant and
what they were trying to do you know one
of the most dramatic things that
happened during apartheid was that South
Africa moved from being labor scarce to
having huge surfaces of labour when
apartheid began there was almost full
employment by the time it ended
unemployment was was way way up and if
there'd been another system a
politically integrated system but it
probably couldn't have stopped that but
it could have managed the fallout in
much more gentle ways so instead you had
a population becoming surplus and and
being shunted around by this
bureaucratic machinery that was cranking
itself up and getting more and more
powerful and more more angry and part of
that was the prison system and so
prisons and prison gangs preceded
apartheid but by the 1970s the sheer
number of prisoners and the per capita
in prison and incarceration rate in
South Africa was absolutely
extraordinary that's a messy history
which is missing from the book you know
the book is in the middle of things it's
watching from close up I think that's
probably the most important part of the
messy history and and that's that's
where these gangs are located in in the
just after the high part eight areas
when there is when I read there really
are there Heights because of what's
happening in the world around them and
what are they trying to do I'm I mean
the story of non gulosa is such an
incredibly complex story but but one of
the things that the story is Israeli so
obviously trying to do on its surface is
to give the people who who tell us
historical and political agency is ready
to place them in the center of history
in the spine of history so the story of
non Gaza is a it's an archetypal
narrative of liberation and indigenous
people is colonized and they're
proletarian eyes dand then they resist
but but the difference here is that the
heroes are not the ANC or Nelson Mandela
who don't figure in the story they have
they're invisible there they have no
role the hero is a criminal it is it is
rarely it attempts to put the marginal
right in the center of history to give
them his
cool agency and yet the sadness of the
story and my mood here I think that
comes to to your comments is that the
people telling the story are so far away
from being able to actualize it so
there's this massive yawning gulf
between the story they're telling and
what they're doing between their their
narrative and their practice because
really their practice is is really a
response to this chronic existential
demotion see which is their prison life
I mean yes Jim I mean absolutely there's
there is a semblance of order in the
sense that the blade has to be so long
and that the majority of prisoners
actually come out and and not
slaughtered there but it is in a sense
an organized state of nature it's it's
it's close to violence explosion always
and it's orchestrated by waters to be
saw that's the easiest way to run the
prison and so it's an unbelievably
almost unfathomably ritualized world in
parts to stave off the state of nature
to stable for this Hobbesian world i
mean i hadn't read ren Asia are when I
when I wrote this book but his book on
violence and sacrifice could easily be
describing this world sacrifice as a as
an act that stems the state of nature
that stems chronic and incessant
violence and halts it by killing
somebody and then making them sacred as
opposed in in violence it's it's so
cares me in retrospect that that's one
of the things that's going on here
and another thing going on another
chronic emergency that has to be dealt
with again and again and again is the
scandal of men sleeping with men which
which in this world is in terrible and
and so much of this ritualized energy is
about making a terrible no through an
enactments of exaggerated misogyny and
so the story the narrative of non loss
areas is real reach for dignity for
historical agency to be to be placed in
a world in a meaningful way and yet the
conditions of existence in this
institutional life make that impossible
there they are by their nature degrading
and yet and I think if this does come
out quite clearly in the number
and yet these people the bearers of the
story do from time to time end up
playing pivotal roles in the very center
of South African history and that's
whenever there's an uprising whenever
this mass unrest so in 1976 at school
students who begin the unrest but it but
it it gets its mass character and it's
its Menace and its power when when
gangsters join us that that's when it
becomes really powerful and menacing and
again in the instructions of 1984 to
1986 again it's begun by activists but
it develops its Menace and its power
when people who have called combed
sorties which I guess translation would
be comrade criminals join us people on
on this cusp between a criminal life in
a political life somewhere in between so
the people who actually staffed the
barricades and struggle against
apartheid are these people people who
knew all about non gulosa and about the
number but this history nonetheless
remained invisible activists didn't know
about it so if they did didn't care much
for us so it is a strange confluence of
a formal proper dignified liberation
history and an underground criminal
history touching each other at pivotal
moments and actually changing history I
mean the end world to to end that story
is is after-parties I mean in a sense
this world helped deliver South Africa
from apart it's in a complicated kind of
way by occupying the streets and the
first thing the post apartheid
government did was ramped up the
incarceration wave by 2006 years after
the end of apartheid the caps and murder
rate was incarceration rate was higher
than it being at any point during white
rule and that wasn't out of malevolence
or menace it was again out of a lack of
imagination about how to govern a very
very difficult place and so the world of
non gulosa
lived on healthily flourishing after
apostates again because of limitations
of governments but in a way that the
world really didn't understand and given
an anecdote about that
a documentary with the the country's
Constitutional Court's great deal of
thought was placed about where it
supposes and then the end it was decided
to put its at the sites of apartheid
most infamous prison the fort just to
show the history of where Constitution
came from to show the bitterness of the
history and I remember watching an early
documentary on on the court and and one
of the Constitutional Court judges was
giving a tour with a camera following
him and he said you know we chose the
fort because this is where the British
locked up the birds and then the birds
locked up black people and now we tired
of locking people up so we built our
Court here and as he spoke the per
capita incarceration rate was higher
than had ever been before and a couple
of decisions he was involved with made
that happen so it really is it's such a
mercurial history because it's a
repressed history it's one that doesn't
really find its place in national
discourse it's it's not known because
it's hard to think and I guess that's
what excited me most when I Istanbul the
process and was researching us that this
mattered a great deal to a country's
political history and yet its political
discourse couldn't really find a place
to to name as who understand us I
haven't quite answered you good but
maybe maybe in the questions okay so we
we have another 25 minutes would anybody
on the panel like to respond to anything
Johnnie said or anyone else said and
then we'll open it up I would like if
you wouldn't mind as people who read
this book I'm sure people on the panel
are curious about the post book history
of you and wensel and in a sense he
would have been if you like a an
anonymous character or would have
disappeared you with all the
difficulties that involved I'm wondering
how he has
survive your book and what is subsequent
history is and history of your
relationship to him yeah it's a
difficult history so the book was book
was published when about 18 months after
he was released from prison mmm and he
had invested very very heavily in in the
book and what it would he was famously a
reformed gangster he was going to leave
jail and he was going to make a living
being reformed accident that was his
vocation and his career and his was
going to be his source of income and the
book in South Africa did very well and
people came to him and and wanted to
work with him and this Mahmud goes to to
what you you were saying each of these
endeavors failed after a month or two
you know he having lived you know this
dramatically institutionalized life you
know he's entire adult life had been
either in a prison gang or lurching back
towards a prison gang and now he'd left
them forever but other institutions were
not going to contain him including and
especially do good NGOs which wanted him
to work to a program and so he was a
middle-aged man who who was never going
to fit into the rhythms of a middle-aged
life that he had imagined he was not
going to find his humanity that way nor
was a Christian for that matter and so
these these endeavors failed again and
again and he got poorer and poorer and
ended up living in a self constructed
wooden house you know in a very poor
area of Cape Town and and as he got poor
our relationship soured
it was he was angry with me he was angry
with the NGOs he was angry with the
world we came together again a few years
ago because a movie was being made at
the bookends and I agreed to give him
most of the person so we had a business
relationship if I'm not mistaken he
[Music]
predicted what you just said that is he
said how do you expect people who were
told when to sleep when to eat when they
can watch tell her that his whole life
has been regimented administered right
how do you expect them to not want to go
back to how do you expect him to live an
autonomous life outside because why his
insight is quite extraordinary hidden it
is extraordinary and and the tragedy is
that he now had nowhere to turn because
he'd he'd the gangs had exhausted his
soul he didn't have a choice he couldn't
really go back there and yet nobody
caught any other rhythm okay
any questions comments
Susan is partly picking up on your own
answer because as you said the book is
about one guy in one prison doing things
right and you're and the question is
generalizing it to something and those
are all I'm sure a wonderful very
insightful insightful tale but how do
you fit that story into a general story
about prisons about I mean there's this
which has to do with the relationship
between the prisons and the political
system in which they're operating the
way in which they're resourced and
organized that that are that's beyond
the particular case that you're I mean
that's not so difficult because you you
know the book is driven by somebody's
life and this person's life is all in an
institution and at some point the story
in order to tell the story you'll want
to know something broader about policy
about the structure of the system and I
guess it's a narrative book so as long
as you don't do it clumsily and suddenly
break away from the narrative to you
know once you write me narrative you
have to keep with it but but I think you
can organically stay with a person's
story and keep describing the world
around them and and why the institution
there is therein is what it is so I
think the sort of institutional history
that you talking about scan can fit
quite naturally into into the sort of
narrative form
so how was that happened all the time
actually well III had to report to the
Department of Correctional Services to
to one of its Deputy Director General's
every four months and she would
interrogate me for hours and I'd walk
out stumbling and exhaustion yeah I mean
for for them I was kind of a fly on the
wall as sort of source of information
that they didn't usually get so they
they really made me pay my way for that
I guess I want to say something for the
value of this book in general the way in
which the texture has you understand
things about race and incarceration that
you will never understand with the
larger picture I mean I the Nate Shaw
book for example there's a scene in this
book that I'm there many scenes in this
book that actually are embedded in my
mind but one of them is when Nate Shaw
who's a black southern sharecropper
needs alone and he there's a hardware
store owner with whom he has credit
relations and he knows the performance
of abject deference that he asked to do
in order to ask for this loan and he
goes and does this performance and gets
his loan and from a larger perspective
of course he reinforces the southern
hierarchy of race and deference and so
on it's just and he comes back to his
family
completely triumphant because he has
given a successful performance and put
over that performance and gotten what he
wants he doesn't feel in the slightest
bit degraded he feels that he's put one
over on the man and gotten sort of the
loan it's very complicated and of you if
you just left it if you didn't see how
he understood that act you would miss a
lot about
southern racism and public performances
well would you say you learned about
South African politics and political
history as a result of doing this that
you wouldn't have learned kind of
everything um I mean really what I've
just spoken about was about the I guess
the cultural and political history that
produced the people who stopped the
barricades and why they stopped them and
what they were thinking and doing you
know formal political history borrowed
from this history it borrowed its
personnel it borrowed its people at
borrowed it's it's Mayans and its
emotions and yet it's it's it's an
entirely buried history and they
informed histories of South Africa you
simply appear in the barricades you're
on the edge of a kind of appreciation
and understanding for the lump and
proletariat in general are you not
notice I'm hanging of the people in the
barricades in 1830 and 1848 in Paris
yeah proletarians anyway I just there's
a this is a history of I wouldn't use
the word a little bit proletariat but
it's the only word everybody understands
I mean there's I guess there's all sorts
of comparative work to be done and then
the different prison systems you were
talking abouts were were interesting and
they're family resemblances between all
of them absolutely I guess yeah I was I
was quite concerned to say that this
isn't a concentration camp
simply because most people walk out
alive and now that it seems an important
distinction to hold on to
you know all the questions we're asking
you have an assumption which is that did
you see the world in this raindrop I'm
wondering whether that was your
motivation I mean did you go to the
present to understand the world or did
you go to the present to understand the
present I mean what did you go there to
do what was your motivation I would be
very interested because we're just we're
all understand interested in the world
and our and the orientation to the
prison is completely instrumentalist in
a sense but it was very much to
understand the world because when we you
know when I went in you know I happen to
go in on a writing assignment side-eye I
wasn't particularly interested in
prisons I kind of stumbled in I was 32
years old I considered myself and
usually informed about my country's
political history had been deeply
involved in it all my adult life and yet
here was an institution that was older
than the oldest liberation movement
older than the ANC had a continuous
presence throughout the country for
generations told this incredibly
elaborate political history and not only
a tire never heard of it but nobody in
my world my political world had heard of
its people saturated in the country's
politics so it became for me became
absolutely obvious that I needed to go
back and and explore it's much more and
to ask what it was and and why it was
that we hadn't have heard of it it was
no coincidence you know what had said
about political history in general that
this massive you know pervasive movement
which attached generations you know
millions of lives it was invisible so
that that was my motive what you know
why why it was there but not there
thank you my question is in the absence
of law and order there is a soft and
possible order whether it be in West Los
Angeles South West Los Angeles or Bronx
and then Hammoud also mentioned in Kenya
where there are officers in the white
neighborhood or Indian neighborhood
where are absent in the minority or
majority camara areas or so forth so my
question is what has apartheid but also
race has to do with this and the
stratification of phrase and the second
question is once people live present you
you you've mentioned it that there is a
lack of I mean if someone spent twenty
thirty years in prison when they leave
they have no idea half the world and
they are I I have to confess that I've
worked with ex-offenders for the for 15
years and so forth and and they are
scared to death they prefer to go back
to prison because it's a rhythm
elementary as you see it and predictable
so some would make commit a crime and go
back so in America it is it is people
are stigmatized and very hard for them
to find a job and how is in South Africa
where they have access to resources
employment in such thank you yeah these
things aren't measured as well in South
Africa as they are in in America so so
the studies are considerably more
limited but it seems the story is much
the same the recidivism rate is is very
very high it tends to stop when people
his about 45 years of age
and people generally stop going back to
prison then but from from 18 to 45 I
mean there were citizen races is
extraordinary people going seven eight
nine times to prison during that time
and and sort of losing a crucial stage
in the life cycle and never been able to
to recover it so so it's the same story
it's an it's an extremely damaging story
I mean you're absolutely right there is
always order and and the gangs in South
African prisons you know are lurching to
a form of order but the price that they
pay is enormous Lee enormous lee hye-in
in violence and and I guess in becoming
a sort of personal sort of human being
who is going to find it very hard to
adapt to be another sort of human being
again note that that touches on on what
you saying I think that if you if you're
looking at people's searching for
humanity it's very important to to look
at the rhythm of their life and their
age and and and and what happens at a
particular moment in their life you know
somebody like maka Dean had this sort of
range of of ways of looking for meaning
and one was through the gangs and
weirdly enough to be colored in in in
the number gangs one becomes human by
borrowing a Zulu history you know you
become one of no Goliath children and
therefore become Zulu and and there's a
sense that there there isn't sufficient
depth isn't sufficient
history in being coloreds so to to
withstand one to know to hold one up
it's not a solid enough foundation when
becomes Zulu in order to become human
it's very tragic story you know the
other options are the opposite there to
become Muslim and and the very deep rich
history in the Western Cape that's that
holds and another as you say is is a BC
Christian legacy and each comes with its
own networks its own institutions its
own ways of being I think that all of
those are very very hard to latch on to
an answer and
inside when you've spent the first 20 or
30 years of a lot life in prison
they they all become very very hard to
grasp and if you can grasp - to stay
Hocus to keep you know I think it's for
many of these people becoming old is
it's a process of sliding away very hard
to attach and and and no one's life down
who wants to turn the prison into a non
prison you're not really I don't know
the subsequent history of the second man
but the subsequent history of the first
Johnny Johnson he became this Khoisan
fundamentalist firstly there was a
terrible racial fights in the prisons
among waters between black and colored
waters which which he got very very
damaged by and got demoted and
marginalized and when that happened he
became a choice on nationalist and grew
his hair long and and wrote a family
histories you know wrote a heritage
about who he was and came yeah he came
to see me a few years ago but he'd lost
his job in the Prison Service he was you
know cobbling odd jobs together
he was devoting his life to to this
heritage but in very very adversity was
an enormous ly charismatic and
impressive prison border and the fact
that he lost all of that was was quite
difficult
watch so we were pretty much out of time
I did think in the course of the
discussion of one other other book that
fits this this category of of bioethanol
fee that we've been talking about and
that nobody's brought up but it's it's
about American psychic American
psychiatric hospitals and it's like go
Paul's book and like Johnny's book it's
it looks at the the realities in this
case of state mental hospitals as well
Susan Sheehan spoke is there no place on
earth for me and if you were going to
read one book about psychiatric
hospitals in America that would be the
book if you're going to read one book
about Afghanistan it should be go Paul's
book and if you're going to read one
book about South Africa it should be the
number so thank you all for
participating thank you for coming and
it's really been a pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]